So we've talked about world views, but what world views should we talk about?
Talk about what world views are, but what world views should we actually talk about?
What world views are your students most exposed to?
Now there's a lot.
We're only gonna touch a couple of the most popular world views
and we're gonna talk about some of the more dominant ones
as well as what a biblical world view starts to look like.
But the first one that we're gonna talk about is the idea of naturalism.
Now you can tell right out of the gate probably the idea of naturalism has the idea
of nature.
Think of your senses.
Think of the five senses that you have, what you can taste, touch, smell, and feel.
Naturalism teaches that only those things are what constitutes reality
and there we're back to that word again.
What is reality?
So when we're talking about these other world views,
they're doing the same thing that we're trying to do.
Trying to talk about what is reality and what is truth.
How do we interpret these things in light of what naturalism actually is?
So those who believe in naturalism are trying to take the five senses
and interpret reality and dictate what is true based on those factors.
That's essentially what they're doing.
And this really, if you think about your students,
especially those in public schools,
this is exactly what they're being exposed to every day of the week.
It's this idea of naturalism,
especially those students that are in STEM research type classes,
science, math, et cetera, technology, those kinds of things.
Because the sciences are very much focused on the idea of what we can observe,
what we can see, what we can touch, what we can taste, what we can feel.
Those kinds of things.
But also what they're trying to do is they're trying to not only figure out reality
and truth,
but they're trying to figure out meaning.
Meaning naturally, life has meaning.
And this is where it gets a little bit tricky.
Is the naturalism point of view, the naturalism world view, is trying to figure out,
well, what does it mean to have meaning in life?
Well, that's sort of sticky because naturalism actually can't do that.
From the viewpoint of naturalism being told that any meaning in life has to be found
then through science.
So science is the only one that can determine what kind of meaning there is.
But science can only take us through the natural world.
It doesn't consider anything else.
And we'll get to more of that in a second.
But what I want you to get though is that this lesson is more than just
understanding what naturalism is.
It's being able to see that it can't work.
And that what we want our students to be able to determine is that they're not going
to get away from it
because it's the dominant view of Western culture.
But to be able to see things through it and interpret things in line of it
and understand that naturalism might be trying to do these things
and might be trying to explain meaning through science in the natural world,
the natural order of things and all that,
but at the end of the day it doesn't really work.
Why?
Well, because naturalism is most closely associated with the idea of atheism,
which means no God, it cannot explain two fundamental questions.
It can't explain the universe in terms of how and it can't explain things in terms
of why.
Now, science is trying to do this.
Science is trying to figure out how the universe was created
and how things got here and how it is that we're all here.
But science can't do this.
It can't determine why.
Is it just random? If it's random, why is it random?
We could keep asking that why question over and over and over again.
And to dig a little bit deeper, it also can't do things like determine justice,
love, morality.
How do we determine those things?
How do we bring up the reality that there is justice in the world?
How do we bring up the reality that two people love each other?
And that we should have love for our fellow humans and humankind?
Why is killing somebody else wrong even if it might benefit me?
Why is stealing wrong?
Why do we understand some morals to be universal for all cultures of all people of
all time?
Where do we get these things from?
See, this is where naturalism falls short
because when we're talking about things like justice, love, and morality,
these aren't tangible things that I can grab hold of.
These are not part of what I can taste, touch, smell, and physically feel.
I can't do that with justice necessarily.
I can't really do that with morality.
These are things that are deeper than what is on the surface
and require a deeper explanation.
So again, it's important for us to understand not only what naturalism actually is,
but it's also important for us to understand that naturalism doesn't actually work.
So in your small groups, especially in your small groups,
make sure you take the time to allow students to sort of discover and discuss
how naturalism sort of manifests itself in Western culture.
What does that look like?
Where do they see that in their schools and in their classes?
It's not just evolutionary science and those kinds of things.
It might be deeper than that.
So get your students to sort of have those discussions discerned.
Get them to see beyond just the surface of what naturalism is
and have them start to analyze it in terms of reality and truth.
One thing great about this Bible study is that we dive into Ecclesiastes
and the things that Solomon wrote.
And I think he had this spot on.
And it just brings so much more to the surface when we consider this book
in light of naturalism.
He writes in the very, very beginning, right out of the gate,
meaningless, meaningless, says the teacher, utterly meaningless.
Everything is meaningless.
What does man gain from all his labor at which he toils under the sun?
Generations come and generations go, but the earth remains forever.
And what he's getting at through this whole book
is the idea that without God putting meaning in life,
life is meaningless, that all of our work and all of our efforts
and everything that we stand for is meaningless.
So think about it.
From a naturalistic perspective,
without God, what is justice?
Without God, what is love?
Without God, what is morality?
Why are we working besides to make money?
Why is there any nonprofit organization at all?
Why do we care about clean water around the world?
Why do we care about any of those things?
Because from a naturalistic worldview, there is no meaning behind those things.
There's no point to doing it because we're all just going to die
and be dust and everything is going to go away and we cease to exist.
But because we have the inclination to want to provide clean water,
because we feel a sense of justice,
because we understand certain morals are universal,
because we love one another and we're called to love one another,
we understand that there's got to be something greater beyond
than just the natural world.
There has to be the supernatural world.
There has to be a Creator God behind all of it.
So we see so clearly, and I want your students to see this as well,
that when we talk about naturalism, it might sound so easy and so simple.
When we talk about that big buffet of worldviews,
it might sound like, oh yeah, this idea works really well.
But when they go down that buffet and they decide that,
yeah, I believe in naturalism and I don't believe in God,
but I believe in taking care of orphans and widows
and providing clean water to children around the world that don't have it,
those two things are now inconsistent.
Those two things no longer make sense together.
It's a great thing that you want to provide that for those people,
but why do you want to do that?
So this goes back to what we talked about last week,
with the idea of it has to be consistent.
So if you're going to desire to want to take care of your fellow man
and take care of people who can't take care of themselves,
if you have that sense of justice and you have that sense of morality,
why?
Again, it takes us back to here and naturalism can't answer that.
So naturally what we would say is that your worldview then needs to adjust.
So help your students navigate this.
This is a little bit tricky and this requires some good discussions.
Again, we'll keep reminding you,
always, always, always let the discussion flow,
let students be honest about what they think,
but challenge them in their thinking.